[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
happy wednesday everyone i am brian
kilmeade as you can see
i'm sitting in a normal chair not one of
the small ones custom crafted to fade
craig's abnormally childlike frame
i'm a full-grown adult
we also had the stage crew remove the
sippy cup because i don't spill unlike
the normal host who's not anything but
normal and most people don't know this
but i'm actually thrilled to be here my
whole life i love late night tv you guys
remember late night tv when it was great
steve allen
johnny carson jay leno that's what we
grew up watching for example when i was
an intern across the street at 30 rock i
interviewed david letterman before he
had his beard and when he used to be
funny uh i gave him that t-shirt so for
me to be here on the number one late
night show is truly an honor and i'm
honored to be with the panel you have
yet to meet
a lot of people don't know that but
david letterman uh just opened up to his
biographer and he quote if i can just
quote him exactly if we can roll back
the prompter he said
that was indeed that was the moment and
the one highlight of my career i will
never forget close quote
i made that up and i could be sued
but it's no secret i co-host fox and
friends the number one morning show and
all cable news
and because of that i don't uh i gotta
con confess i don't really watch the
show in fact i did not even know greg
was full-time and had a show of his own
gutfeld is on when i am fast asleep i
don't wake up until like 2 30 and i
understand
greg talks about me a lot i don't know
exactly what he says but i have a few
clips that we can watch together
so never let a crisis go to waste
a phrase coined by kilmeade's barber
this is male pattern baldness is in the
shape of belarus like brian kill means
fleas that's a head scratcher like kill
mead's doll collection does make me sad
it's like when kilmead enters a crowded
elevator
they treat him like he's got monkey pox
it's likely someone no one can stand
i call them creeps but why offend brian
kill me
this is good news for lazy and competent
workers
are you gonna force employees to wear
patches just make sure it's for a cause
that everyone can support
that wasn't exactly what i was hoping
for
well that hurt more than when greg
reached up and hit me in the shin one
time i got married
but i can take it i'm a big boy unlike
him and it's an honor to be the first
non-cast member to guest host this week
because kat and tyrus were unbelievable
monday and tuesday
i am told
according to reports i am told i was on
the top of the list and obviously that's
true and we even got some behind the
scenes footage of the selection process
so this is kind of cool let's watch
listen guys it's wednesday afternoon we
still don't have a guest host for
tonight anything
i'm sorry i thought brian stelter
couldn't say no
well look whoever we get remember what
greg always says you got to treat him
with dignity and respect
i know i know look i thought of some
other names here um martha mccallum uh
dentist appointment um bill hammer dogs
dance appointment maybe we need to think
outside the box like uh i don't know
like a chris cuomo
you know greg has that emergency guest
host envelope i just can never remember
where he keeps it probably somewhere no
one would ever look
[Applause]
oh wait a minute i know someone who's
definitely available
hey brian what do you think about
hosting this show today
yes you are our first choice
i found greg's envelope
anyone
but
kill me
well hey at least we have the judge
tonight right
good thing i had high self-esteem before
the show
too late you stuck with me so let's do
this thing let's talk about the big
story of the day which is president
biden's desperate attempt to get votes
forgave a 300 billion dollar loan
program it's a campaign scheme to get
democrats reelected in november to me
also known as the student loan
forgiveness program or as the college's
colleges call it bribery
in between naps potty breaks and ice
cream cones with sprinkles the president
found time to announce a huge deal to
throw free money at tens of thousands of
young americans yup the way his son
threw cash at tens of thousands of
strippers and might have done that
already today
and just in time for the midterms too
the liberal media well they're eating it
up like they were brian stelter having
his last meal at the cnn cafeteria
president biden acknowledging in his
words that a ticket to college has
gotten too expensive and pointing out he
is keeping a key campaign pledge he told
a really i thought heart-rending story
about why it is personally so important
to him his family could not afford to
send him to college and he talked about
how his father felt ashamed this is yet
another victory for for the president
and his supporters and as you note uh in
your view for the rest of the country as
a whole um take off your political hat
on that front everyone would like to
have their their loans paid down and go
to college
we're doomed
the plan calls for a one-time maximum
debt forgiveness for ten thousand
dollars for borrowers who make less than
125 thousand dollars and up to 20 000
for pell grant recipients and it will
cost you the american taxpayer yes
everyone in this audience 300 billion
dollars is there any mathematician in
the white house the plan also extends a
repayment pause through the end of the
year so don't worry about not making
your payments until december but who's
really going to benefit from biden's
plan the upper-class democratic voting
bloc while blue-collar workers who
actually have skills get shafted so if
you pay your bills and live within your
means and pay off your loans you ladies
and gentlemen are a sucker but the
president sees no problem with that in
his delusional world it is fair
is this unfair to people who paid their
student loans or chose not to take out
loans
is it fair to people who in fact
do not own the multi-billion dollar
businesses they've seen what these guys
give them all attachments is that fair
what do you think
does that make any sense to anybody in
this room
the president getting a little feisty
out there he's always angry i'm not sure
why the cato institute my favorite
institute by the way lays this out says
there are several reasons federal
student debt cancellation is a bad idea
first it helps the winners those who
made the decision to go outrageously to
go out to uh to go out to outrageously
overpriced colleges and get a degree and
the higher the degree they earned the
more money they will make and supposed
to pay off their debts wouldn't you
think that it's not like those doctors
will give you a rebate when your
colonoscopy pays for their mercedes
follow that for a second there's no
coupon available it's also regressive as
more of the aid would go to the highest
earners than the lowest again giving
money back to those who need it the
least how does that make sense not to
mention the huge cost to taxpayers and
that's more reckless than paul pelosi
entering the indy 500.
thank you jesse waters now if president
biden decides later to cancel 50 grand
per borrower it would cost taxpayers one
trillion dollars and for giving the
entire amount 1.6 trillion dollars
further the student loan handouts would
incentivize greater inflation since
neither universities nor future students
would believe future loans would have to
be repaid like today's freshmen and cato
also calls the legality of the biden
decision noting that the constitution
gives congress not the president the
power the purse which is especially
frightening given the president doesn't
have power over his own bladder for the
most part
as usual
the right-wing extremists are putting
down the president cue it
people think that the president of the
united states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power
president can't do it so that's not even
a discussion
yep when you lose nancy pelosi you lose
everybody and let's talk about the real
problem here college cost they have
soared multiple times the rate of
inflation over the past century and the
costs just keep going up it's not like
the graduates are getting smarter if
they were we would they wouldn't
complain about pronouns am i correct
they complain about the interest rates
in our country perhaps i mean take a
look at this chart of private school
costs over the years lots of numbers
lots of bars all going in the wrong
direction and public schools no better
also cost an arm and a leg you can't
argue with charts they're put together
by mathematicians statisticians and
estheticians oh wait uh
i got confused i'm talking about the
good people who put together nancy
pelosi's face every day
the point is
college costs are a lot of money and
they have endowments in the hundreds of
billions of dollars but not when you're
a college inflating cost knowing it goes
past the taxpayers so biden has made
good in his promise to partially wipe
out student loan debt but not
everybody's happy and you knew it was a
matter of time before it would turn into
a
race issue
woke educator nina turner tweeting this
out canceling 10 000 in student debt
when the average white borrower is
twelve thousand in debt while white
excuse me black women hold over fifty
two thousand dollars in debt is not uh
is just unacceptable it is drum roll
please structural
racism
i'm old enough to remember when biden
and the democrats passed the inflation
reduction act or as they privately call
it the take the money and run act
bottom line is the wall street journal
nailed it when they said it would
benefit the spendthrift of the
responsible it's vote buying at its most
raw that pretty much sums it up
cash for votes which is only slightly
less annoying than cars for kids
[Music]
give your car sorry about that it's
going to be in your head the rest of the
day
but it also seems unethical to me off
the also although it what do you expect
from the president united states
remember
you're low on cash you can always join
the chinese gas company's board of
directors
just tell them the big guy sent
you let's welcome tonight's guest she's
the only judge who owns her own ex
who does her own executions co-host of
the five judge geneve heroes
these are
he's our favorite charlie after brown
and horse fox news contributor
washington times editor uh charlie hurt
is with us live
it ain't laundry day so she can't
pretend it's blankets not booze that
have her three sheets to the win fox
shoes contributor cat tim barely sold
them
i'm not sure that man it made a lot of
sense in rehearsal sorry
he grabs bulls by the horns and greg by
his underwear the naa is world
television champion tyrus welcome
that's our show thanks for joining us
that was the longest open i've ever had
yeah that is like five uh fox and
friends you have 11 stories in that
sorry cat um i'm gonna spend the whole
show making up for your introduction uh
tyrus let's start with you is loan
forgiveness racism well i like you
already wow that's great yeah greg never
picked it right now
wow it's amazing it's all right man yeah
i also liked your book so that yes you
did you actually read it good um
he's the great enabler in chief this is
what he does man he's he's a bad parent
as we talked about with hunter and he
it's the same policies with how he
governs he throws money on things
although in this case he this is a
boomerang thing it's like it's like a
rebate for donations so the people that
supported him they're going to get a
nice little check for their spoiled
brats who are still living at home
because their ferrari needs you know new
stuff so
this is goes back to just the it's so
frustrating but this is the best thing
for
the american working class people when
they go to the ballot box november
they're going to be like wow he is not
for us at all he is about himself this
is always about the elite these are
first world problems because i'm be
honest with you i couldn't pay my
student loan when i got out of college
and i just had a pell grant
so i didn't pay it for like 10 years and
worked in fact i answered the phone
over call my stop no
you know click no he's not here damn i
was on the limb i ran i built my stuff
up i got myself together and then
eventually they call and said hello yeah
i'll be like to make a payment today
right you know what i'm saying and and
that's what a lot of us were forced to
do or the ones who just paid it right or
even worse the moms and dads who didn't
go on vacations didn't buy the new car
didn't have the amazing christmases that
put the money away that sacrificed so
they could put their kids through
college so what what are you telling
them that's great i know what you're
telling them
for the other panelists because i don't
know if they can match that analysis do
you still you still want to try or do
you want to call it a day
cat here's what uh jason furman said
treasury advisor to
uh obama as well as biden pouring
roughly a half trillion dollars of
gasoline into the inflationary fire that
is already burning is reckless doing it
while going beyond our one campaign prop
for a campaign promise of ten thousand
dollars and breaking another uh breaking
another proposal so it's paid for is
even worse his own side is complaining
about this
yep
[Laughter]
yeah obviously i mean i'm just starting
to think biden just like loves inflation
because i mean
i don't unders what other explanation
for that is there and i get sick of
calling it forgiveness or cancellation
because it's not that it's just stealing
from other people is all it is
and
i i also paid off my student loans i
also struggled for years after college
but what people say often is they say
okay well just because you suffered do
you want other people to suffer but they
don't understand that actually by doing
this you're making people in the future
suffer too because the price of college
is going to go up even further that's
how this all started that it got so
expensive was the government it's going
to get even worse so charlie is be the
19 to 22 year olds or the 25 year olds
get their student loan forgiveness what
if you're 38 and just finished paying it
off what if you're 45 52 and you go wait
a second well i am an idiot for making
my payments and if i'm a freshman why do
i think that i'm gonna have to pay that
loan back well at the heart of it it is
fundamentally unfair and that's what uh
that's why i think that's what sticks in
the craw of so many people especially
people who have worked so hard to to do
that but but um
what does let's not forget what this is
what this is it's this is a bailout of
colleges and universities that colleges
and universities don't need
you know harvard has a 31 billion dollar
endowment
uh and they're not alone
that might be the largest but they all
are rolling in cash and cat's exactly
right the reason that college is so
expensive is because throughout this
entire scam college uh tuition
loans scam the federal government has
been the bookie at every step of the way
and they get their cut and they and and
so for biden to do this is rewarding
right uh the system and that's exactly
right you think tuition is going to go
down next year no tuition's going to go
up and it's going to go up because of
this and interest rates are through the
roof some of these loans are 10
i mean that's almost criminal that's a
loan shock that is a loan charge but you
know what's interesting about this as
you say college tuition is going up not
in terms of inflation but the same way
that the loan forget that the loans are
going up so it's almost like there's
this there's this scam that's going on
where we're going to indoctrinate your
kids we're going to make sure that your
kids believe in socialism it's almost
like this socialist contract between the
government and education and then we're
going to forgive the loan in the end for
the people who are rich and don't need
it by the way if we have such a great
economy why are we giving these people
money it's not like they can't go out
and get a job and the bottom line is
this you want to give money away give
money to the veterans give money to the
senior citizens who can't afford to go
out and get what they want and in the
end
in the end what they're doing is joe
biden knows that he's unpopular with
kids and young young people 53 of people
under the age of 35 disapprove of him so
he's paying them to vote for him and
it's disgusting and by the way if you've
got a contract you sign it you agree to
pay it back and if you don't pay it back
don't worry about it we'll pay it back
for you that's not the america that we
were raised in well you can't do it and
remember you have those monthly payments
and if you have to take a pause you go
to the bank unlike tyrus who speaks
another language uh you you got you
called the bangor listen i need to pause
uh yeah it did uh and you wait 18 months
you come back and you're paying more but
at the end of the day you made your
payments uh and that's it it's called
setting up a credit rating too then when
you go to take out a loan to maybe get a
car or something
then you have a foundation to build on
but that's what we have today elizabeth
warren's happy most of america isn't
before we go i'd love to see you on my
tour i'm going to be on stage go to
briankill briankillme.com i'll be in a
place called the egg it sounds
prestigious up in albany and then i'm
going over to uh tulsa oklahoma uh
that'll be on november 13th so a little
bit of a pause and over in mississippi
and brandon so i'll see you all there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else